congrats on an amazing game where did
this incredible strategic mind come from
i think my mind
just has to see things clearly i always
need to be able to visualize what i am
doing
so
i needed a plan or it was just going to
be difficult for me to move forward i
knew we wanted to do something together
i knew we had a mission i think my mind
just functions in the capacity to fix
things if everything is jumbled my brain
will try to
unscramble it line it up and make it
make sense so i think that's just innate
in my mind that if something does not
look clear to me or something needs to
be better i'm always going to try to
improve it and so that was essentially
how i developed the master plan
this season of big brother will make
history the first black winner ever and
you were a huge part in making that
happen that's historic what does this
mean to you and what do you think it
means to others out there
wow to me
this means everything i have always
valued and respected history it is the
blueprint of how we move accordingly in
this world or how we move forward to
make my mark in history to have my name
set in history has always been a dream
for me so
even though for some people it is a
reality show for me and the other five
people on this journey it was a mission
of ours and to be the first to
accomplish such a great mission is will
always be an honor to me to have made
the part in it or play the part in it
that i did
for everyone else i hope that it is
taken as uh people joining together for
a common purpose for um having unity
together being able to set our own
personal differences our own personal
desires aside just showing the world
that people can actually come together
all different
from different places in this world we
have never spoken before we had no idea
if we could really trust each other or
if we would even be loyal but we had
blind faith we had blind trust we had a
mission and
covertly we accomplished it and if
people can just see that
how we work together i think a lot of
people will be able to accept that and
recognize that they can work together to
accomplish anything
the game is always harder than you think
it will be expect the unexpected what
was the most unexpected moment for you
this season
oh
i honestly was unexpected
my most unexpected moment really was day
one i expected there to be some
diversity i never expected there to be
so much diversity and
really coming together with people who
accepted my differences and my weirdness
we did not just have diversity in color
we had diversity and personality these
people were very smart not just the
sticks not just the people in the
cookout but the entire house i'm like
where are the people i can play on their
minds everyone was a challenge in this
house just having so many smart
intelligent
wise bright people to work with was very
unexpected i'm like who has never
watched this show everyone knew
everything
what would you have done differently
biggest regret in the game
i thought that
the way i won
bibino's my second hoh
was not
appreciated in the house with the
cookout i think that
said
um it just put the icing on the cake for
them to want me out first however i
don't think that
that would have changed anything
i have to realize that the master plan
was really a big deal for them and they
always wanted me out right away so
whether i would have taken it upon
myself to win that second hoh or not i
do think i just still should have let
them know prior to that it was my desire
but i was going to do it anyway so no
regrets
who do you want to stay in the house and
who do you want to join the next injury
because of the hard work that we put
into the six i have to also know that we
all took played a part in that so i
really want a great game player someone
who also was working on their mission in
the six but also playing the game to
stay in the house i would like to see
either
kylan and xavier in the final two or
hannah sitting next to either kylan and
xavier in the final two
you